what about the fear of death how does
this change it
again to me death is when I stop
experiencing
and I never wanted to stop I want I want
to live forever
as I said last time every day the same
day forever or one day every 10 years
forever any of the Forevers I'll take it
so you want to keep getting the
experiences then you experience gosh it
is it is so fulfilling just the
self-growth the learning the growing the
uh comprehending
it's it's addictive it's a drug just a
drug of intellectual stimulation the
drug of growth the drug of knowledge
it's a drug
but then there'll be thousands or
millions minosas that live on after your
biological system is no longer more
power to them
do you think that in quite realistically
it does mean that interesting people
such as yourself live on
in the uh
you know if I can interact with the fake
manolas those interactions live on in my
mind
so it makes sense about 10 years ago I
started recording every single meeting
that I had every single meeting we just
start either the voice recorder at the
time or now a zoom meeting and I record
my students record every single one of
our conversations recorded
I always joke that like the ultimate
goal is to create virtual me and just
get rid of me basically not get rid of
it like don't have the need for me
anymore yeah another goal is to be able
to go back and say how have I changed
from five years ago was I different was
I giving you know advice in a different
way was it giving different types of
advice has My Philosophy about how to
write papers or how to present data or
anything like that changed
and
I you know
in in Academia and in mentoring a lot of
interaction is my knowledge and my
perception of the world goes to my
students but a lot of it is also in the
opposite direction like the other day I
had a conversation with my one of my
postdogs and I was like hmm I think you
know let me give you an advice you could
you could do this and then she said well
I've thought about it and then I've
decided to do that instead and we talked
about it for a few minutes and then at
the end I'm like you know I've just
grown a little bit today thank you like
she convinced me that my advice was
incorrect
she could have just said yeah it sounds
great and just not do it yeah but
by
constantly teaching my students and
teaching my mentees that I'm here to
grow
she felt empowered to say here's my
reasons why I will not follow that
advice
and again part of me growing is saying
whoa I just understood your reasons I
think I was wrong
and now I've grown from it and that's
what I want to do that's I you know I
want to constantly keep growing in this
sort of bi-directional advice I wonder
if you can capture the trajectory of
that
to where the AI could also uh
map forward project forward the
trajectory
after you're no longer there how the
different ways you might evolve so again
we're discussing a lot about these large
language models and we're sort of
projecting these cognitive states of
ourselves on them but I think on the AI
front a lot more needs to happen so
basically right now it's these language
models and we believe that within their
parameters we're encoding these types of
things and you know in some aspects it
might be true it might be truly emergent
intelligence that's coming out of that
in other aspects I think we have a ways
to go so basically to make all of these
dreams that we're sort of discussing
come come reality we basically need a
lot more reasoning components
a lot more sort of logic
causality
models of the world and I think all of
these things will
will need to be there in order to
achieve what we're what we're discussing
and we need more explicit
representations of these knowledge more
explicit understanding of these
parameters and and I think the direction
in which things are going right now is
absolutely making that possible by sort
of enabling you know chat GPT and gbt4
to sort of search the web and you know
Plug and Play modules and all of these
sort of components
in Marvin Minsky is the Society of Mind
you know he truly thinks of the human
brain as a society of different kind of
capabilities
and right now a simple a single such
model
might actually not capture that and I
sort of truly believe that
by sort of this side by side
understanding of Neuroscience and sort
of new neural architectures
that we still have
several breakthroughs I mean the
Transformer model was one of them the
attention uh sort of aspect the you know
memory component
all of these you know the representation
learning the pretext training of being
able to sort of predict the next word or
predict a missing part of the image and
the only way to predict that is to sort
of truly have a model of the world
I think those have been transformative
paradigms but I think going forward when
you think about AI research what you
really want is perhaps more inspired by
the brain perhaps more that is just
orthogonal to sort of how human brains
work
but sort of more of these types of
components well it's I think it's also
possible there's something about us that
uh in different ways could be expressed
you know Noam Chomsky you know he wants
to you know we can't have intelligence
unless we really understand
deeply
language the linguistic underpinnings of
of uh of reasoning but these models seem
to start building
deep understanding of stuff yeah because
what does it mean to understand because
if you keep talking to the thing and it
seems to show understanding that's
understanding it doesn't need to present
to you a schematic of look yeah this is
all I understand you can just keep
prodding it with prompts and it seems to
really and you can go back to the human
brain and basically look at places where
there's been accidents for example the
corpus callosum of some individuals you
know can be damaged and then the two
hemispheres don't talk to each other so
you can close one eye and give
instructions that the
that half the brain will interpret but
not be able to sort of project to the
other half and you could basically say
you know go grab me a beer from the
fridge and then you know they go to the
fridge and they grab the beer and they
come back and they're like hey why did
you go there oh I was thirsty turns out
they're not thirsty they're just making
a model of reality they're basically you
can think of the brain as the employee
that's like afraid to do wrong or afraid
to be caught not knowing what the
instructions were
where our own brain
makes stories about the world to make
sense of the world
and we can become a little more
self-aware by
being
more explicit about what's leading to
these interpretations
so one of the things that I do is every
time I wake up I record my dream I just
voice record my dream and sometimes I
only remember the last scene but it's an
extremely complex scene with a lot of
architectural elements a lot of people
Etc and I will start narrating this and
as I'm narrating it I will remember
other parts of the dream and then more
and more I'll be able to sort of
retrieve from my subconscious and what
I'm doing while narrating is also
narrating why I had this dream like oh
and this is probably related to this
conversation that I had yesterday or
this probably related to the worry that
I have about something that I have later
today Etc so in a way I'm forcing myself
to be more explicit about my own
subconscious
and I kind of like the concept of
self-awareness in a very sort of brutal
transparent kind of way it's not like oh
my dreams are coming from outer space
and I mean all kinds of things like no
here's the reason why I'm having these
dreams and very often I'm able to do
that I have a few recurrent locations a
few recurrent architecture elements that
I've never seen in the real life but
that are sort of truly there in my dream
and and that are that I can sort of
vividly remember across many dreams I'm
like oh I remember that place again that
I've gone to before Etc and I and it's
not just Deja Vu like I have recordings
of previous streams where I've described
these places
so interesting these places
however much detail you could describe
them in
you you can
you can place them onto a sheet of paper
through introspection yes through this
self-awareness that it comes all from
this particular machine it's exactly
right yeah
and I I love that about being alive like
the fact that I'm not only experiencing
the world but I'm also experiencing how
I'm experiencing the world sort of a lot
of this introspection allows the
self-growth I I love this dance for
having uh you know the language models
at least GPT 3.5 and 4 seem to be able
to do that too yeah you seem to explore
different kinds of things about what
um you know you could actually have a
discussion with it of the kind why did
you just say that yeah and it starts to
wonder yeah why did I just say that yeah
you're right I'm wrong
I was wrong it was doesn't yeah and then
there's this weird kind of losing
yourself in the confusion of your mind
and it of course it might be
anthropomorphizing but there's a feeling
like
almost of a Melancholy feeling of like
oh I don't have it all figured out
almost like losing your you're supposed
to be a knowledgeable a perfectly
fact-based knowledgeable language model
yeah and yet you fall short so human
self-consciousness uh in in my view may
have a reason through
building mental models of others
this whole fight or fright kind of thing
uh that that basically says
I interpret this person as about to
attack me or you know I can trust this
person Etc and we constantly have to
build models of other people's
intentions
and that ability to encapsulate intent
and to build a mental model of another
entity
is probably evolutionarily extremely
advantageous because then you can sort
of have meaningful interactions you can
sort of avoid being killed and being
taken advantage of
Etc
and once you have the ability to make
models of others it might be a small
evolutionary leap to start making models
of yourself
so now you have a model for how other
functions and now you can kind of as you
grow have some kind of introspection of
hmm maybe that's the reason why I'm
functioning the way that I'm functioning
and maybe what Chachi PT is doing is in
order to be able to again predict the
next word it needs to have a model to
the world
so it has created now a model of the
world and by having the ability to
capture models of other entities when
you say you know setting the tone of
Shakespeare or in the tone of Nietzsche
Etc you suddenly have the ability to now
introspect and say why did you say this
oh now I have a mental model of myself
and I can actually make inferences about
that